Well, here we are. It's Will. I've Sean and Jason aren't here yet, but I just want to say don't be naughty on this all-new smart list. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
Bless. You know what though, being in London, thank you. That's right, Matt, thanks everybody. Sean's got material. No, I don't. So listener, let's catch you up. Sean is in London doing another run of Goodnight Oscar.
What a production. Thank you for bringing it back. Thank you for Europe, it's much more convenient for me and my travels. Goodnight London. Goodnight London. Buona sera. Buona sera Oscar.
No, by the way, I'm looking at my window at Westminster Abbey. Can you believe that? Isn't that wild? Got yourself a nice place there, huh? Am I going to wait, oh yeah, can you show me my room? Listen, I'm about to live with Sean. You're going to go stay with those guys, huh? Yeah, remember how you used to do that when you would travel with Sean
and go to all these wonderful places around the planet? Well, I get to do one now. You know what's so funny, when I heard that, I actually thought about your sort of crappy little voice being sad about that and then how you were gonna be excited that you were going to stay with Sean. Yeah, I love it. It's no Istanbul, but it'll do.
No, it's better. Or Venice, or Venice. Or Venice, that's a tight second. Both of them. But, Sean, it's going well so far? You remembering to look right when you step off the curb? Isn't that wild? I really am trying to get, and by the way,
you know the other thing? When you're walking on a sidewalk, I have to go to the left. No, you don't. What are you talking about? You're going to pass somebody. No. Yeah, because they're hoping you do that.
Are they? I'm telling you. No. Yeah, I'm telling you because I lean to the right and they're like, and then they lean to the right and then I lean to the right. They keep going to the right. You've been leaning right for years though.
I think you and Will are going to jump parties on me soon. Wait, but you know that like you walk around London and you're like, wow, I get why JK Rowling wrote Harry Potter. Like it's so magical. Like it's incredible here. No, I do love that place. It's incredible. And people that live here that I talked to,
they're like, yeah, you know. Just kidding Rowling? What's that? Just kidding Rowling? Is that what it is? Just kidding Rowling, JK. Will, you've been to England, right? Do you like Europe? Do you've been to England, right?
Do you like Europe? Do you like England, London in particular? And here he comes. Don't try to bait me. Don't try to, it was a classic bait, man. Don't try to do it. I'm not gonna do it. Willie, why don't you come out?
Why don't you come out? Why don't you just move there? I don't know why you got yourself. I am gonna come out. Sean, I made a plan this morning. We're gonna come see your play in August. I'm not going to, we're going to go over the dates. I'm coming, Bradley and I are coming in Chappie.
No way, that's so nice. By the way, you can- You guys doing some reshoots? We're doing reshoots, yeah. We have tons of room, Willie. You can stay with us if you want. Fantastic. Yeah, it's unbelievably beautiful.
Well, that I'm very excited for, but I hear you got there and it was in kind of shabby shape. You had to bring in a deep clean company? Yeah, when we got to this place that we got. No, no, no, no, not deep clean, but it has an elevator because it's an old townhouse. Oh, boy. And of course the elevator broke down. No, while you were in it again?
Oh, man. No, I wasn't in it this time, But I keep a bottle of Valium in it. You know what, can I just say something? It might be user error at this point. Can I just say something? It might be what? User error, I think it's your fault or Scottie's fault. Yeah, sure.
This is important to say at this juncture, which is because just in the times we live in, and I think that for you to be able to speak so openly and so bravely and so relatably about the shabby shape of the elevator in your townhouse in London. Yeah, this is the second dwelling you've been in with an elevator.
I've never been in a place with an elevator. Oh, but yeah, I'm renting it, I don't own it. But it's really beautiful. But it's, you know, so I keep a bottle of Valium in the corner in case it goes, but I did my exposure therapy. You don't need a full bottle, why don't you just keep one in your pocket?
Well, no, no. A bottle of Valium in the elevator? In the elevator, in case it shuts down and I have to wait for the repair guy and I don't need a full bottle, why don't you just keep one in your pocket? Well, no, no. A bottle of Valium in the elevator? In the elevator, in case it shuts down and I have to wait for the repair guy and I don't go crazy, so I'm just, I need, you know. Why don't you just put a gun in there? Put a gun in there and then just put it deep into your fucking mouth.
Wait a second, first of all, your fucking therapist needs to be arrested. Because this is, that's absurd. No, I'm telling you because if something goes wrong and you're stuck in there for an hour while the guy gets there, I don't want to go crazy. I just want to like chill out. Well, that ship has passed.
Well, why don't you look within, man? I did, so I did exposure therapy and it's kind of working. What, you just get on the tube and just flash your jacket open? Yeah, it's really working. What does that mean, exposure therapy? So it's really fascinating. You sit there with your palms up and your eyes closed,
you have to repeat over and over a million times, you have to go, I'm walking down the hall, I see a small elevator and I step inside. I'm walking down the hall, I see a small elevator, I step inside. And you say that over and over and over again, for like 20 minutes, and your therapist will check in every two minutes
and say, where's your anxiety level? And it goes from 10 to eight to seven, to three to two to one, until you become bored with it. Then you move on to, I'm walking down the hall, I step into an elevator, and then the doors close. I'm walking down the hall,
I step into the elevator, and the doors close. And you just try to feel what that feels like over and over again, and it fucking works. And what are they charging you an hour for this? I don't remember. Because I used to do this in elementary school, when I would screw up, they'd make me write stuff on a chalkboard over and over and over again.
Like Homer Simpson. Yeah, it's called sentences, or whatever. Hey, you know what else works, Sean, is nutting up. Yeah, it's just called developing the backbone and the thicker skin and just getting older. You know? No, I know. You've been through a lot in your life
and you are tough. I mean it, like you know how to deal with a lot of stuff and you get your head on your shoulders. Yeah, but it's claustrophobia. I mean, if you got stuck in that elevator that I had stuck in, you would've gone fucking bananas. Will, what's your plan today? Will, what Well was your planet out there in the Hamptons? My plan is pretty it's a little overcast and rainy. I was already I was up super early
Going over stuff with with a friend BC and Going over stuff. Yeah The edit he's working on the, right? How's stuff looking? It's looking pretty good, so we're doing that this morning early, I was up like five because he's in Europe and then. Aren't you close to getting a cut that you like?
Yeah, I mean, it's a work in progress, he's working away on it. Has he shown you his director's cut yet? There is, no, there's no director's cut yet, no, no. Okay. But, and then, you know, do my usual Are you happy with your performance that you've seen? I am yeah, I mean, I don't know it's no I'm happy with watching his performance. It's pretty I mean, it's it's something like you're starting to see yourself and in its context with
The one scene stuck next to another scene next to another scene like that's like it's a scary thing Like how's it's starting to feel, good? I think that we have a movie, I'll say that. You've been doing it a lot longer than I have, JB. You know how it is, and so you never know until you know. So I'm just kinda leaving it out there in software. Are you allowing it to become something different than what you had imagined it was going to be?
Yeah. Because inevitably it is. As you know, it always changes. I'm excited for you to see it, for both what you had imagined it was going to be. Because inevitably it is. As you know, it always changes. I'm excited for you to see it, for both of you to see it. Sean's in it as well, and Sean's great. So he's still in it. You're saying he's still in it? Yeah, as of this morning.
Okay. This morning. But I'm excited for you guys to get your thoughts. I can't wait. To hear your thoughts on it. I'm wide open. That'll be be forthcoming, but we'll see. What else are you excited about? Our guest today.
Well, I'm excited about our guest today. I know, I know. Sorry, Sean, we'll get there. I was about to, I was just answering the question. Sean, are you in a rush? Yeah, he's got a dinner. Are you, I'm sorry, are your knickers in a twist? Yeah, are you keeping the palace waiting?
By the way, we're so lucky, we're so lucky because now we do get, we get to get to our guest, which is gonna be just, he's a palate cleanser in every way. This guy is so, he's done everything. And he's one of those guys who classically trained, Juilliard trained, and then so he's done everything from Broadway to like Indies to like, you know, cool plays to the biggest of biggest of biggest of hits.
He's like just a bona fide movie star. I've had the pleasure of getting to know him a little bit over the last couple of years because we've worked together on a project together, me and a producing role, but him as the star of, he's incredible. You guys know him from all his performances, the second I start to name it, Sean's gonna go,
I know who it is. He's been in a gazillion Marvel movies, and within the Marvelverse, he then graduated and became a sort of a different character altogether. You know him as Captain America. I know him as Anthony Thank you, I have so much to say about those first Like I wanted to see which one of y'all is gonna talk about who had the most Tesla's in their driveway Jason had the most Teslas in their driveway. That'd be Jason. That'd be Jason.
I've never owned one. I'm trying to get it away from my wife, but she will not. Anthony, by the way, you should know that Jason's glass house is so fragile up. He's in his guest house overlooking his screen house, overlooking his main house right now. Okay?
Anyway, Anthony Mackie, dude, thank you. Thank you for being here. Welcome to Smart List. It's so great to have you. Yeah, it's so nice to meet you. No, thanks for having me, man. I appreciate it. It's been a long time coming.
Yeah. It's been a long time coming. Where do we find you? Are you at home? No, I'm in Budapest right now. And I'll tell you what. Wow. A black man in Budapest for the summer is,
I mean, god damn. It's like, I found my people. I don't know what, I don't know. It's like they shot me out of a rocket and landed me. Like I did something right in my life. You know what I mean? They're like, you get to go to Budapest for the summer. You know?
What do you mean? What do you mean they just love you there? Well, everybody loves you everywhere. No, it's different here. Like everybody's nice, like the food is good, the city's beautiful and historic. You know, there's a dirty river, like just everything you want.
You know, every day is sunny. The Budapestians are fucking great people. I love them. I love that. There's a lot of stuff that's shooting there lately, huh? Like, what are you doing there, can you say? I'm doing a show for Apple, so nobody will see it, called 12, 12, 12.
12, 12, 12. Gotcha. Apple is huge, people will see it. Yeah, come on. Yeah, Apple is great, man. Yeah, it's like this F1 thing, that's making a lot of money. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Apple's great, man. Formula One, like it's this F1 thing that's making a lot of money. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Apple's great.
I'm excited. It's my first time, well, my second time on Apple because I did the first movie on Apple, actually, The Banker, and this is my first time back. So they've been great, man. It's been wonderful. They gave me the opportunity to come to Budapest for the first time. Amazing.
So how, is it a bunch of episodes? So you're there for a while. It's eight episodes. It's me and Jamie Dornan. So they're, this is our second time working together. I'm like, you know, it's, we're and Kari who directed Falcon Winter Soldier is directing it. Oh cool.
So it's a pretty good, it's a pretty, pretty good group. Great scripts, like great stories, you know, it's a good time. And it's in Budapest. It sounds like it's big, it sounds like there's a lot of action. It's huge, you know who you're talking to? Yeah, yeah. Okay, you're not the only one, I mean it's huge, buddy.
We're doing well here, you know? It's okay. It's action and it's stunts and it's a muscular project, yes? It's a lot of testosterone. Some might call it toxic, but I don't give a fuck. A ballsy ring. Ballsy.
So how long you there? If you're doing eight episodes, you're there for five months? Five months between here and London. And it is like, when I come to London in two weeks, I'm coming to see your show too. Yes. Yeah, I'll be there, I'll be there.
Should I wear like my Liza Minnelli shit? Like Moe and Beyonce shit? Yeah, for sure. Okay. I know we're not going to be. Tommy Jones stuff works too. We're not going to be open in two weeks, you come back in July.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, two weeks is in July. Oh, well, end of July, July 31st. Oh shit, you've been. August. So you go back and forth, you guys shoot stuff in England, you shoot stuff in Hungary, back and forth. No, I'm shooting Avengers in England and I'm shooting this in Hungary. Okay, gotcha.
Wait a second, so you're going back and forth to London, you're doing Avengers, Sean, hold your questions. No, I just. Sean is a massive, massive Avengers Marvel. And you're working with, you have the misfortune of working with Downey, Sean is a massive, massive, adventurous marvel. And you're working with, you have the misfortune of working with Downey, I'm sure, over there with Robert. I mean, what a trip.
Hey, he serves up a great lunch, man. I mean, everybody's healthy, you know, it's really good. We drink his bottled chill brew. It's a good time, it's a good time, it's a good, we drink his bottled, chilled brew. It's a good time, it's a good time, it's a good time. So Anthony, with all this time away from home, what's the main thing you find yourself missing? I ask, because it's on my mind, I just had my daughter call me from,
she's on a trip to actually also to Europe on some sort of camp thing, and she's feeling really homesick. But so, what are you missing most about home right now? Yeah. I hate to say this because it fits in y'all's conversation earlier, but I miss my cars, man.
Yeah, yeah. I miss driving when I'm away from home. I just want to, I'm a very, very like home-strucking dude. So literally I'll go, after going to the gym, I'll get a po'boy and a ice cold beer, sit in the garage and work on my cars all day. Wait, so after the gym, you find a real fatty, carbohydrate-ridden snack and some puffy-making beer.
Sorry, Jason's one of those guys who doesn't eat pizza, by the way. Exactly. But I came out with a big fat face. I gotta like spend every minute of every day trying to- But that's the whole point of going to the gym, man. You go to the gym and you're like, then you go get a po'boy.
Exactly. I exercise so that I can be a little bit bad. I don't exercise. Well, you look great, man. You look like you're- Anthony, I love you. You look like you have one of those pelotons. You know what? You look like you do Pilates is what it is. How dare you.
So you miss driving, you miss your cars. Where's home, LA? You do have like a Pilates, not your body, but your temperament and like the way that you are in the world, you seem like a Pilates person. I tell you what, I am hearing that that's what I need to make a friend of, is Pilates. Yeah, it's good stretching.
It is good. So it's got all the stretching of yoga, but it's got some core strengthening, muscle building stuff. Anyway. I heard it gives you outstanding sexual stamina. Wait, what? He doesn't need that.
That's what I heard, dude. I heard a friend of mine started doing Pilates. I could use a little bump in that as well. Thank you. I like it. Just maybe another 20, 30 seconds would be a friend of mine started doing a little bump in that as well. Thank you Just maybe another 20 30 seconds would be Wait Anthony's Speaking of relationships. I love this. I love this I'm just waiting for you to get your first fucking question. I'm
My clothes are off. Go ahead. Wait. I love it. I love it, JB. I'm telling you I love it. I'm having fun. It's fun. Do you notice that, Sean? He brings on a guest. He just sits back. He basically introduces them and then he's like, okay. Not at all. We're having a conversation. We're having a conversation. And you were asking... We covered a lot of shit. This is going really well.
Yeah, this is going really well. Yeah, this is going very well. How dare you? Oh, sorry, okay. Move on to the taint exercise. Anthony, just to make J.B. feel better. Anthony, how'd you get your start in show business? Ha ha ha!
Which I really do want to know. By the way, J.B., you will be jealous. Let's talk a little bit for a second. And Anthony, I've asked you about this in person too, like, you went to Juilliard, which is so rad. It's like the gold standard. I mean, that must have been, talk a little bit about like, getting into Juilliard,
and was it like a dream come true, or were you like, yeah, big good job? Did you have a cross pass with Laura Linney there? I think she's a big wig over there. I never saw Laura Linney. She was never there when I was there. Patti LuPone was there all the time, which was amazing. But it all started in New Orleans.
I mean, I went to this school called New Orleans Center for Creative Arts, which is pretty much like fame, but in New Orleans. And I just loved it. Like, it was amazing. It taught me everything and I got to, New Orleans is a very segregated city, so getting to meet and see people
from the other side of the city was mind blowing how different it was on the other side of the track. So it forced me to want to get out of New York, I mean New Orleans. So I went to boarding school in North Carolina at North Carolina School of the Arts. And I consider that to be my year of time. Like everybody's been arrested,
my year of jail time was in Winston Salem, North Carolina. Oh really, why, why? Why, it was bad. Have you ever been to Winston Salem? No, no. It was really bad. Winston Salem in 1996 was some shit, you hear me? Oh really, really.
So I made it out, I did my bid, I got out, you know what I mean? And the man couldn't hold me down forever. So I moved up to New York and auditioned and got into Juilliard from North Carolina. And moved to New York when I was 18. And it was crazy. Wait, so Anthony, so you grow up in New Orleans. You were born and raised there? Yeah, born and raised was crazy. Wait, so Anthony, so you start, so you grow up in New Orleans, you were born and raised there?
Yeah, born and raised, yeah. Seven-Wall Boscoville hardhead. So then your first real exposure to, as you say, the other side of the tracks was going to this really cool art school where you got to see some folks that are from a different socioeconomic background and they're coming to see some of the productions and stuff like that.
The seed gets planted to be an artist, an actor, yeah? And you say, okay, I'm not bad at this, you're getting some nice accolades? Such that you think you can take on more? Not at all. It was just, it was something, I was probably the worst actor at my school, but. Really?
It kept my interest, you know? Like, you know, the idea of being in a room with different types of people and doing different types of shit, it was almost like every day was summer camp. Like, I looked forward to going there every day, because you would go there half a day and then regular school half a day.
And it was just like a bunch of people in a room that I identified with, people that I got along with. And it was a school that was half dancers, so we had all these smokin' chicks in a dance program. So I was like, fuck. I just showed my, I have a 16-year-old son, I showed him my year I have a 16 year old son, I showed him my yearbook from high school and he was like, yo, those are the girls. And I'm like, this
is what girls looked like when I was in school. Fuck you. Like you got it good. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Was it a common thing for the folks where you grew up to like go into the arts, become an actor, go to this art school? Not become an actor. I mean, in New Orleans, you know, every little boy grows up wanting to be a trumpet player. You know, everybody wants to be a musician. Everybody wants to march in a parade.
Right. But were your parents musicians or in the arts at all? No, hell no. My daddy worked. My daddy was a roofer. So it was six of us. He had to work. So my mom was a-
Oh, fuck, roofing in New Orleans too. That is not- Yeah, my mom was a homemaker and my dad was a roofer. So it, but they always pressed on us education and going to school. So it was very important to them that we did something that fulfilled our dreams and kept us interested. But also probably they had their eye on practicality too.
It sounds like they were not afraid of good hard work and some pleasant predictability about income and providing, were they sort of, you sure you want to pursue acting or the arts is something that like, how about getting like a quote unquote real job? Was there pressure for you to do that as well? No, not at all.
My parents, my dad had one rule, do whatever you want, be the best at it, just don't go to jail. Oh, that's cool. That was it. Like you can be a damn garbage man, just be the best garbage man and don't go to jail. That's it.
Like growing up in New Orleans in the 80s and 90s, it was such a rough city. It was, I mean, it was the murder capital of the world. I mean, there were, in a city of 700,000 people, four to 500 people were getting murdered a year. So, first square capital, we were literally the murder capital of the world. Wow, I didn't know that.
So, yeah, it was wildly dangerous in the early 90s. Did you have brothers and sisters, or were you an only child? Five of them, yeah. Wow. We're all vastly different and very different. Anybody else go into the arts? No, no, no, no, no, yeah. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. And we're all vastly different and very different. Anybody else go into the arts? No, no, no, no, no, no.
My brother was a singer, but he also played tennis, so all that shit's weird, you know what I mean? So, I mean, that's amazing. So you go and then you go to North Carolina, then you go up, you get into Juilliard, you go to Juilliard, and I was under this. So you graduate Juilliard, you've got a degree from arguably like the premier place to get an acting degree,
certainly in the States, and is it like, okay, the day after you graduate, is it like everybody's knocking at your door, or is it just to hit the streets and start auditioning like everybody else? Well, you do this thing called league scenes and you invite all the agents and all the agencies to come see the graduating class do their monologues. Like a showcase.
A showcase, yeah. And everybody comes and from that, hopefully you'll get an agent or a manager. And I got lucky. I did these three scenes and they were fine, it was cool. But what really helped me was when I was in school, we wrote this play about Tupac called Up Against the Wind.
Yes. And we all did it. Like, there was a girl, Rosemary in a directing program, Michael in a writing program and all of us actors. We all wrote and produced the scene ourselves, I mean, the show ourselves at school. So when we did the show, Jim Nicola from New York Theater Workshop came to see the show
and was like, I want to move this off Broadway. So it was a big problem at Juilliard because you're not allowed to do outside work while you're a student. And it came down. But it was a gray area because you guys had started it at the school. We started it at the school. Right.
And it was very eye opening because there was a fight between me and the staff if I would do this play off Broadway which was created at the school or if I would do the checkoff play, which was created at the school, or if I would do the checkoff play for my final grade of the year. Right. So we were going back and forth about that, and they were very adamant
about not letting me do this play. And then the play caught fire and took off, and all of a sudden, everybody was a supporter. Like there was a teacher who was interviewed by the New York Times, and true story, this is still in print, she said, usually the black kids just sit around and wait to see who's going to play our fellow,
but it's great that they created something that they can go and do in the New York theater. Whoa! What? What does that even mean? It means she was a fucking idiot? Yeah, what it means she was a fucking idiot That must have lit a fire on your like a little bit to be like like I'm gonna yeah like yeah
And that was my biggest thing like coming out of that school It was it was really eye-opening for many different reasons, because I went to go see a play like every two weeks, and I saw so much bad theater, but I saw so much good theater. Yeah. You know, and so much small theater, and innovative and courageous theater.
And it really just formed and shaped me. What I saw really formed and shaped me more than what I learned in school. Yeah. And now, you find yourself, sorry Sean, you find yourself at a place of great success with tons of momentum and futures wide open. Did you allow yourself to see yourself at this place,
at this age, or are you kind of like, you know, it's a tough question to answer, but are you where you thought you would be? Are you over performing, under performing? You've got to be happy. You've got to be content. You know, this is a weird business. And you know, psychologically it's a huge mind fuck
to be a part of this business. Because I never thought I would be here. Like I never, when I got into this business, I didn't say, oh, I want to be famous, or I want to be a movie star. I literally dreamed about being a working actor. Like I wanted to work at the Guthrie, I wanted to work at Penumbra.
I wanted to work- That's why you've had longevity. And that was the focus of my career. Like, how can I do these great roles, you know, these great American theater roles in great theaters around the country, you know? And it just so happened, you know, because it sounds like such an asshole story.
So, when we were doing up against the Wind, there was this amazing casting director named Molly Finn, Guy Russell. And she was in New York, she came to see the play, and Curtis Hansen was putting together 8 Mile. Right. That's right. So she came to see the play, I get to audition for Curtis Hanson, and I was always a huge fan of Curtis from LA Confidential, from all the shit he had did. And my audition, like it was just funny,
I always had a belief, if you get people to direct in you and working with you, that's because they're interested in you. If you audition and they go, good job kid, thanks for coming in, then nine times out of 10, you ain't getting that job. So I walk in and I meet Curtis, sit down, Curtis was a cool cat, like love him to death,
and I asked him, I said, so that was right when, like a year after Wonder Boys had came out, and I said, Curtis, I have a question for you before we start. He's like, yeah, sure, go ahead. So I was like, Wonder Boys. I'm like, was that meant to be an ode to Alfred Hitchcock or were you directing it in a sense towards the ideals and teachings of Hitchcock in the way he worked?
So he goes, whoa, what are you talking about? What do you mean? So I explained to him what I saw in the movie and what he did with Tobey Maguire and the backdrops in the scene and the escalating visual aspect that tied into the mental frustration of the character. And we talked for like an hour about Wonder Boys.
I never read, never did my audition. So I come out and I'm like, fuck. Oops. I blew my time. I blew my time. So I'm like, don't like fuck. Oops. I blew my tie. So I'm like don't do that again. Don't do that again. So three weeks later he called and he was like yo cast somebody else in a role that you came in for but there's another role. It's only four days. If you, I don't want to
offend you. I know you're a trained actor, but if you're willing to do it You know, I'd love to have you in Detroit. So I'm like hell. Yes, Curtis Hanson. Yeah, so fly to Detroit and Just sit with Curtis Hanson and eat dinner and like kick it for like two weeks And this for a little only was four seniors. Yeah, right and He was like You have anything booked after this. Right? And he was like, you have anything booked after this? I said, no.
He was like, well, so if I extend your role, you can stay. I'm like, fuck yeah, I can stay. Ain't going nowhere. So they extended my contract to a run of Pitcher. And we developed that role over the course of two. That's really cool. And that's kind of how it started. That's amazing. That's amazing. That's so cool. And that's kinda how-
That's amazing. It started. That's amazing. That's so cool, you guys kinda built it off a person, like just like a dialogue that you were having with him about like a shared interest, like that's so- That's what's so funny in the movie, like Eminem has that rap at the end of the movie
where he's like, you went to private school and all that shit. If you of the movie where he's like, you went to private school and all that shit. If you go back, like he's, we had a conversation a week before and we're talking shit and you know, M is just an amazing dude and a lovely human being. Once you spend time with him, it's just funny but he's always learning
and hearing and listening. Like he's like a fucking sponge. So we get to set the next day and he's like, yo, there's no reason why I don't like this dude. Like, yeah, we beefing, but nobody knows about our backstory and our history, so we need to put that in the script. So Curtis was like, yeah, yeah, yeah, you right, you right. So it comes the battle scene, right?
And I write my rhyme, I'm like, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom. Right, we go to set and fucking Eminem starts his rap and he's like, you went to private school. I was like, I did go to private school. He's like, your parents have a real good marriage. I'm like, my parents do have a real good marriage. You motherfucker, you talking about me.
Big man. Yeah, that's cool, that's cool. Wow. Now wait a second. Wait, so was, was Eight Mile your first movie? That was my very first movie. Yeah. Wow. Yeah, that's pretty cool.
That was 2001, man. That was my first movie. Nice start. That was my first job. Isn't that crazy? I mean, it was a first massive movie. I know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I did, I did Up Against the Wind off Broadway and then went into Eight Mile. Have you been back to theater yet? Yeah, I did. Well, the last time I did theater was 2016 with Chris Walken and one of the most amazing human beings on earth, Sam Rockwell and Zoe Kazan. We love Sam.
Called Behanding in Spokane. Oh yeah. And I'll tell you what, if you haven't worked with Chris Walken, just save up some money, produce a play, and fucking do a play with Chris Walken. That motherfucker's amazing.
Like that was the pinnacle of being able to do theater, to see him on stage every night. Wow. I bet, I bet. That's really cool. What a cool experience. You know, a lot of people say, you know,
acting is the study of human behavior and there's human psychology and stuff like that. And you've done so many, so many different roles and so many played so many different people. Do you find yourself outside of work, kind of getting people's heads or analyzing people's behavior or analyzing the human behavior outside of a role? Like I find myself doing that probably to a fault sometimes
because I'm like, oh, that person acts like that because of A, B, you know what I mean? Do you do that? Well, no, that's a very interesting perspective and great question because I do that all the time. But in this generation, people are so thwarted with their own insecurities that you can't really ask questions
about why they do something or how they think, because they instantly go on the defensive, because they haven't even thought about why they do the things they do and why they think the way they do., why they think the way they do. Yeah, they don't think that deep. Yeah, and my thing is as an actor, it's really interesting to me to try and understand people
and the knowledge and the aspect of what happened on the course of your day to make you act or react the way you did just now. Right, I love that, yeah. You just ask questions like, why do you think that way? Or what made you think that? And it's like, oh, you're just being an asshole.
And you know. Yeah, because I'll drive Scotty, my husband, crazy. I'll constantly ask him every day, how are you, what are you doing, what are you thinking about, what's going on, you all right? Like trying to get in there, because he's like, yeah, get out of my face, I'm fine, I'm fine. You know?
Like, and I'm always like, but you- Is that right? You're a digger, and he's just like, just let me be quiet. Yeah, like there's nothing wrong. Just completely. Is he really grouchy? Does he seem really grouchy?
No, no, I just want to know. But he goes, if you keep asking me, that's what I'm going to get upset. You know what I mean? Like, go over and over. It sounds like a great match for me. You ever get tired of Scotty, you send him over to me. We'll be quiet in the car together.
We'll be so quiet. Just sit over there and shut the fuck up. But I didn't know, Anthony, if you're like that, Anthony, where anything like me, where if it's in a relationship, whether it's a friend or a coworker or a romantic relationship, whatever it it is I just sometimes overanalyze people to death and they're just like okay stop talking. Yeah I try to and I just ask questions and give them space to breathe and just see what
comes out of that you know but for some reason people take that as you being an asshole and they get upset with you because you try and understand them and they've never tried to understand themselves. You know, and the more I understand you the easier and better this relationship will work out. Like I was having a conversation the other day and my boy was like, you know, you need to come to LA
and go to the parties and meet these directors so people can see you. And I'm like, yo, after 25 years if I got to go to a party at like so and so's house for you to want to work with me then fuck you, dude. You know what I mean?
It's like you've been in this game long enough to where like you know the people that like are doing it in the way they doing it. You know what I mean? Now all of a sudden I got to come to parties and do blow off of Jason's dick for us. the people that like are doing it and the way they doing it. What's this game now? What is this new game? Now all of a sudden I gotta come to parties and do blow off of Jason's dick for us.
Exactly, Jason. Yeah, leave that up to me. But it was a nice short line though, wasn't it? Jason, stop putting blow on your dick. Well, it's mostly just box. I can't really fit a line on there. It's just little upgrades. By the way, you'll hear a funny, I texted this to JB twice this week in the same day. Two
people came up to me and go like, Hey, I know your buddy Jason. I used to party with him back in the day. I used to live in Venice and this other guy, I worked with them on a thing and I texted JB and JB goes, yeah, I put a lot of people into rehab. Bye. They spent a week with Jason in 1995 and they were screwed. They were done. Wait, so you do, Sean brought up, I mean you've done, I mean you've just done countless movies and you've done so many different kinds of characters.
I know, so many. And you're off Broadway, Broadway, obviously we mentioned Juilliard and you do all this stuff and then you were in Hurt Locker, like you've been in all these celebrated films, and then you get asked to become part of the MCU. And what was that process like? That's the Marvel Cinematic Universe, Tracy. She knows that, that's one we don't need to explain. I don't know, is Tracy a big Marvel fan?
She doesn't strike me. Sean's sister, sorry, Anthony is Tracy. She really likes rom-coms. Right, yeah. Oh, okay. So, Marvel Cinematic Universe. Here we go. Here we go.
What was that call? What was that conversation? And were you like, yes, or were you like, ah, skeptical? Was the first one, to Will's question, was the first one Winter Soldier? Was that the first one? That was the first one. Yeah, because I saw you in the, I saw,
I love that movie by the way, I love that movie. And I love all of them, but I mean like, when I saw you it was like, what the, this guy's incredible, like what an unbelievable addition. What the fucking, I mean it's constantly, the character. What were your favorite parts, you know the wings. So wait, so wait, so how did that roll out? How did that roll? Yeah?
But yeah, yeah, how did it feel get the call and like what and oh my god, and what was it? Uh, you know it came together like, you know Like a what oh my god No, I know tell some more no, I just can't imagine getting a call like that. Sean, Sean, if Sean's... If Scotty knew who Sean was about to get the call, he'd put a diaper on him first. Like a little baby chimp about to get his first taste of ice cream.
Fucking what? Running around this townhouse with no elevator. Just doing zoomies. Zoomies on the floor. Tuck in the elevator with a belly full of Xanax. And a diaper full of ice cream. No, but that must have been a pretty cool day. Like, hey, you want to come and join the fucking biggest thing in the cinematic world?
It was really funny. No, it was. It's been a pretty cool day like hey you want to come and join the fucking biggest thing in the cinematic world No, it was it was a it was a really cool call to get You know, but the problem was it wasn't check off at the Lincoln at Lincoln Center So it was like you had you had to think okay Can I can I can I can I bear this and still pursue that right? Like there's a there's a strategic career, gross sort of conversation you have to have with yourself and your team perhaps at times when you get opportunity, right? But that script was phenomenal, I'm sure. It's not like, you know what I mean? Well, but that's the problem with Marvel. You don't know, you don't get to read the
script. You don't get to know anything. Like I had a meeting with the Russo brothers and... Like, I had a meeting with the Russo brothers and... These guys, they're wonderful! Two brothers from Cleveland! But with the great Italian heritage! These two guys! Is our boys really getting... We love our acid development! Anyway...
We'll be right back. Okay. Okay. Anyway. We'll be right back. And back to the show. So the Russo's called, we know Joe and Anthony real well, Josh, JB and I do. And so they call you and they're like, just say yes or no, sight unseen. Yeah. Yeah.
Pretty much, we meet, it was such, it was like the most L.A. shit I've ever experienced. We go to this hotel and it's like all like Art Stucco in a swimming pool in the middle. And it's like all these ladies, these old ladies with like their lobster
titties laying out by the pool. You know, we ordered lunch and they're just like fucking cooking. And Nate Moore and I were like the only two black dudes in the whole hotel. Like it was some L.A. Beverly Hills shit. Everybody has their shades on.
So, you know, Joe Russo, he's the talker, you know. So Joe goes, look Anthony, we have a script, we have an idea, you know, we have a character, and we'd like you to play it. Is that something you're interested in? And I was like, yeah, can I read it? He went, no. Can I know the character?
No. So I didn't know who I was playing, literally. So what made you want to say yeah? Joe's magnetism. Because I knew being in the MCU would like do for my career the same thing, you know, being nominated for an Oscar. Yeah, right. Because at the end of the day, if you go up,
and I always do this with my friends, at the end of the day, if you go up to the average person and ask them who won best actor last year. No, no, no, nobody knows. Right, that's just us. Not even the average person. Ask any of us who won best actor last year. Who won best actor? I have no idea. Nobody knows. Not even the average person. Ask any of us who won best actor last year.
Who won best actor? I have no idea. Adrian Brody. I can't tell you what. Adrian Brody. Go up to the average person and ask them who, average person our age, ask them who played Rocky or who did this. They'll always have those iconic
characters and moments in their mind as opposed to an award push for you to get a statue. Sure, right, right. Right, so in that respect, it's a no-brainer. It's like, like I said, it's like, hey, we're running the biggest deal in the game right now. Do you want to jump on this train? We're going this way, and you're like,
I kind of want to go that way. Hell yeah. But then you let your eyes drift over to Anthony Russo, and you're like, well, hang on a second. This guy has not stopped staring at me, hasn't said a fucking word. Not a word, he just stares at you the whole time. And I want to know what the deal is.
Ant is going to be a stone cold psycho with you while Joe's talking and eating a sandwich. He's trying to distract you with the shiny penny over here. Don't look at my brother. I always find it fun when Joe takes the time out from playing like fantasy football to actually have a conversation with you. That part's fun. Stop looking at his phone to actually look at you and talk to you for one second. I feel like the most special person. He's like the talented Mr. Ripley. He's like, oh man, so how's it going?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And his phone. So what happens, so then at what stage of that whole thing do you get, do you finally kind of get keyed in on who your character is, like what his name is, what he is, where he lived, and then actually reading a script, et cetera, et cetera? Like how far down the road is that? Right before I got on a plane to go to Cleveland,
because we shot that in Cleveland, mostly in Cleveland, some stuff in Atlanta, but I didn't have anything. I was just like Marvel, I loved the movies. I'd always wanted to be in the movies since the first Iron Man. I'm like, I'm down. I didn't know what the movie was.
I just thought, because I had been approaching them, I had had my team approach them a long time before about the idea of playing Black Panther. Like growing up, Black Panther was one of my favorite comic books, cause my oldest brother read all the comic books, so I always, that was like Luke Cage and Black Panther were my two favorite comic icons, along with Superman, but they were my two favorite black dudes.
And we had always gone after and circled the idea of, at some point in time they have to do Black Panther. Like, you know, call them, email them, text them. I write letters to Kevin Feige, fuck you, Black Panther. Right? And, so I thought when they hit me up, they were like, you know, would you play this role? I'm like, of course it's Black Panther.
But then, when I got the script, I realized it was Sam Wilson. And once I started reading the history and the background about Sam Wilson, I realized the importance of him in the MCU. Like what Stan Lee intended for him to be and what he created him for was really amazing and really profound and really spoke to the idea
of the perspective of the black American in America at that time. So it was, you know, him being a part of the airborne was strategic, you know, him being ex-military was strategic, him being a hustler from Harlem was strategic, all of those things were put in there to socialize and emulate what black culture was at that time in America.
So as black culture evolved, so did Sam Wilson in the MCU. So you do that, so you get there and you appreciate that and you start getting into that and then you eventually, and you make, I don't know how many movies you're in, obviously. It's like seven. Seven, yeah. It was like six, seven.
Now this would be my 10th and 11th. 10th and 11th. I mean, how about, hey Russos, hey, how about just a brief cameo? I know, we've been, Jason and I know them. When they were just, they directed the pilot of Rest of the Va, you want to just call us and say, these are two of the oldest...
We've known Joe and Anthony about as long as anybody in town, right? Jason, who knows those guys longer in town than us? Anthony is the end, do not text Joe. That text will be lost in the osmosis. It's unbelievable. Just a couple of nice seats for a premiere would be great. Yeah, that...
Even just a discount at Regal Cinema is what I... You know, I take that at this point. You know what I mean? But so you do... So this is your ninth and tenth or tenth and eleventh. And then when was it that you made the transit when you became Captain America? Because that's a pretty... That sort of mantle was handed over.
When was that? That was at the end of Endgame, which was weird because that's when all the shit changed. Like that's when Disney bought Marvel and Disney Plus became a thing. And after Endgame was when everything turned into this idea of Marvel and Marvel streaming and Marvel TV and all these different entities under the Disney umbrella. So because of that, which I was very happy about because you could put so much in an eight part series as opposed to an hour and 45 minute movie, the Falcon Winter Soldier show was more so about the idea of Sam Wilson becoming Captain America.
And leaving all the other shit behind. So that's what I did after Endgame. Because nobody knew, like on Endgame, I didn't know I was going to fucking be Captain America. Nobody knew that shit. Like when I found that out the day we were on set. I didn't know about that, but that Sunday, Sunday we were at Chris' house watching football,
and I found out at Chris' house that Monday morning we were shooting a scene where I became Captain America, because he had got those pages Wednesday. No way. You guys don't even get a script when you start a project, wow. No, you get a God, you guys don't even get a script when you start a project, wow. No, you get a script, but as soon as you get the script, you put it down and every day you get pages.
Oof. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then they're like, hey, you better read these pages because we're about to change the trajectory of your character, your life, your career. Like, right, like just. Well, so like, is there like a group of like super dorks that are sitting around the table and figuring out how all of these different characters intertwine and like...
What do you mean that's what you wanna know? Look in the mirror, Sean. A one year plan, five year plan, 10 year plan for how all these characters slowly get closer to one another and cross pollinate and like where's the where's the think tank on all this stuff I want to ask the and when does Mickey Mouse come into all of this stuff? You know the idea is the the scope of it all the original plan was the the first you know the first, the first 10 movies,
to have that arc all the way to end game. And then, you know, all the other phases after that, they just build it out phase by phase. So you have the beginning, the middle, and the end of the phase, and how that, you know. I wouldn't even know where to start. I mean, do you see what I start at Iron Man, and like that, if I just started there,
I would, I'd start to get, you do the Iron Man one, two, and three, and then where do you move to? Well, see, this is the problem, all right? Mm-hmm. I don't think you need to watch all the movies. Like, I don't think some of the movies, like the Thor movies don't really, like,
translate into the universe. But there's probably some useful information there that affects other stuff, right? Not really, because that's Thor's own thing. That shit is so far out, it's so different, because he's a god. Like that shit, when you see Thor come into the MCU, you never see anybody go to his universe.
Right, right. So Spider-Man wasn't around, because Spider-Man was owned by Sony, and Spider-Man came into the world on Civil War. So, you don't need to watch any 17 incarnations of Spider-Man. So, the movies you really need to watch are the Iron Man movies and the Captain America movies.
Those are the ones that give you the through line. And that'll get me to Avengers? So Captain America, the first Avenger, and all the Iron Man and Captain America movies will get you to Endgame. Jamie, I think we need to do, you and I need to do an MCU film fest in your new theater.
Please, when are you home? I'm sure one of y'all got a movie theater in y'all house. No, Jason does. I'm sure all three of you have movie theaters in here. I do not. Jason does. It's not in his house. It's its own building. Now listen. So it literally has a different address. Hey, Hamish. Next question. But so you do all that stuff. You do, and now you're, and then you're, I don't know how you find the time to do all this other stuff.
Not to mention the fact that we've got Twisted Metal Season Two, which is premieres end of July. I know, this is like, July. This is the thing you're producing, Willie? Yeah, yeah, on Peacock's. That's end of July. Season Two comes out on that, which is a huge hit for Peacock.
So that's coming out, you're promoting that. Second season's super fun, Anthony's so good, if you haven't seen it, Anthony is so good in it, and so funny. It's a good time, it's a good time, it's fun. You're a band member in a hard metal band? No, but not a bad pitch. No, dad.
We're just on the road with you, it's like stuffing the bus. No, dad. We're just on the road with you, it's like stuffing the bus. No, dad. He's too busy listening to yacht rock to watch our fucking show. Yeah, totally. It's a post-apocalyptic world. It's basically based on a video game. The video game Twisted Metal, which was big in the 80s and 90s, 90s and early 2000s.
We got the property and built out this world behind the lead character John Doe, and it's the post-apocalypse and the world is basically falling apart, but you see John Doe and the rest of the characters trying to maneuver through it and figure out how to get inside what is now the real world, which are these walled- in cities all over the world where society and reality still exist instead of the war zone that's outside the walls. But Anthony, you know, there's so many projects that you're,
I mean, it's mind blowing. Yeah, or, by the way, it would be like, Anthony, Anthony, Anthony, do you remember, like, we would have meetings when we were first working on Twisted Metal. We had a couple, like, development meetings or something, and I'd be like, Anthony, where are you? And he's like, I'm in Saudi Arabia. I'm on a boat.
And he literally was like, I'm on a boat in Saudi Arabia. And I'm like, what are you talking about? All right, so then this prompts the obvious question. Let's talk about domestic life. Do we have a family that we're trying to navigate through all this, or are you just a rockin' single and you just can take your show on the road? No, the one thing I realize is being a,
like I'm a firm believer that I think, like I love to work. Yeah, clearly. I feel like me working is my happiness. I'm with you. I love to stay busy. It's like, that's just my joy. And sadly to say that most of the times when you're gone
for four and five months at a time, relationships don't really fit into that. All of my free time and all of my empty brain space goes to my kids. I have four sons and four little boys, dude. They are so interesting and different and manipulative and just little assholes at the same time. So it's like, you know, you have to, like every free moment I have is a moment to fall in love with my boys.
You know? So I don't really have space. Are they able to come with you on some of these things? Well, they do. They'll come out and visit, but the problem is I have to remember that they have their own life exactly You know like now I'm in Budapest and my boys have worked all school year for two and a half months of summer exactly Yeah, so do I say fuck your camps fuck your friends?
Yeah, you're fun you come to the right right hotel room while I'm at work Oh, right. I see them. Yeah, I get to see you right before you go to bed. Same exact problem. That would be, I would hate that. Yeah, right. So it's a, you know. Well, what hotel? Which hotel?
Negotiate. It depends, the Budapest Hotel. Yo, my boys, they love a good room service, boy. They're fucking chicken wings are. The chicken tenders, shit. And craft service. The chicken tenders. I bet your Marvel puts up a good room service, boy. They're fucking chicken wings are. The chicken tenders, shit. The chicken tenders. I bet you Marvel puts up a nice craft service on set too. Good snacks?
Yo, our crafty is crazy, dude. I'll tell you. And then you can go over to Downey's Camp too and get a little something extra. And then it's crazy-er. But like one day, I snuck over. Well, you'll get your fiber in Downey's Camp. Oh sure, if you're gluten
Step over there when we were when he had the pizza truck I went up to his security securities real cool guy I was like look man I went over to the pizza truck and all them was sitting in there talking I'm like I don't sit in there talk to them motherfuckers I want to make pizza so I go over with the pizza guys and start making pizza on the truck right so I made this Dope delish I mean chefs kiss pizza, right so I cut a piece dope, delicious, I mean, chef's kiss pizza, right? So I cut a piece off, and I go over to Downey Security Goal, and I'm like, yo, man, here's a slice of pizza. Like, I know you've had a long day,
so I just wanted to introduce myself. We haven't met, my name's Anthony, it's so great to meet you. He's like, oh, nice to meet you. So two days later, I'm like, I want to sneak in Robert's fucking base camp. Because he has air conditioning in it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You got an idea or something? I go in my trailer, I don't have ice. I'm like, I know who has fucking ice, right? So I sneak over to Robert's base camp.
I go to the security guard. I was like, yo, what's up? And he's like, Anthony, how's it going? He's like, that was a great pizza, thanks. I was like, hey, you mind if I go in up man? He's like, Anthony, how's it going? He's like, that was a great pizza, thanks. I was like, hey, you mind if I go in right quick? He's like, no, go right ahead. I stole all his fucking ice. That's how it works, kid.
That's how it works. Yeah. That's right, it's who you know, it's who you know. It's who you know. There's no little man on this pole. Well, listen man, we've taken up too much of your time. You're over there, you're working, you're having a good time,
you're probably in your weekend and we're eating into it. Yeah, that's really nice of you to show up. Very nice of you. Anthony, it's always awesome to talk to you. Again, you're the busiest dude I know, and you're such a super talented dude. So impressive. And if you haven't seen Twisted Metal,
please see Twisted Metal Season Two on July 31st on Peacock. Like I said, Anthony's amazing in it. And then your new show coming out next year on Apple, which 12, 12, 12, which is gonna be amazing. And more Avengers and more all of it. And dude, Anthony. Keep it coming, we love it. Keep it coming, continued success, dude.
You're a great dude. Thanks a lot, man, appreciate it. Sean, I'm gonna come check you when I get back to London. Your mind will be loved. I love it, I love it, thank you. I feel like you like Aperol spritz and shit, so we can have like an Aperol spritz. I'll have it, I'll have anything with a spritz in it. I would love that Anthony, it'd be great to see you too.
Yeah, so come on down, I would love it, I'd be so honored. Definitely, will do. Great to see you. Awesome, thank you, thanks Anthony. Thanks a lot guys. Thank Great to see you. Awesome, thank you. Thanks, Anthony. Thanks a lot, guys. Nice to see you. Nice to see you, pal. See you, buddy. Oh, Sean, hey Sean, great job.
Great job. Thank you, thank you. You know Sean's been working with a tutor, an interview tutor? Yeah, mm-hmm, thank you. Yeah, it's subtle, but it's much better. Thank you, I mean, I'm billing her three ways. So how could he?
He's the only nominated interviewer that we've got. There's always room to improve, he said to me in a text. Were you not on that? Yeah. No. How great is Anthony, right? Yeah, he's great. I've never met him.
Never seen an interview with him. And that was awesome. Yeah, he's really cool. He's such a great dude. And when you look at his credits, it's so unbelievably impressive. Not just the volume, but all the different kinds of characters he's played.
I'd love to see him on stage too. I bet he's a beast. Incredible on stage. And you see that like, you see, remember he said early on, he was like, well, you know, you want to come come out you want to do too many different things Because you don't want people right that you're all over the place. I'm like, dude Yeah, I mean he did every he's covered every corner. Yeah, I know and he's got like 17 things coming out soon
I know like there was there was one year There was one year I think where he had like eight movies in theaters at the same time. Are you kidding me? No. Crazy. Oh my God, the promotional work on that must have been a nightmare. That's the first thing you think of. All the stories you've got to come up with.
Oh God. How about this anecdote? You immediately think about the junket. Yeah. That's the first thing you think of. You have to think of like so many different ways on that junket to say... Like what? Good.
No, no, no. Work on it a little bit more. Come back to us, Will. That was just a straight up... You got another one? Well, no. You know what you ought to do next time you're trapped in the elevator? Think of some good vibes.
Yeah. And just put a chalkboard in there, you know what you ought to do next time you're trapped in the elevator thinking some good vibes? Yeah. And just put a chalkboard in there, you know what I mean? Is there a new dad joke you've got for us today? We haven't had a dad joke today, I'd really like one. I did have, did I do the, what did the pirate say when he turned 80? Did I do that one already?
No, uh-uh. What did the pirate say when he turned 80? Well, what? I madey., matey. Hi, matey. That really got him. I just love them so much, but I love them coming out of Sean's face. I know.
You know? Because he's just like, I'm half laughing already when I'm around him. I just put the grin on my face. What did the pirates say after they played the game? They said, I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world.
I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best player in the world. I'm going to be the best he's just like, I'm half laughing already when I'm around him. He puts a grin on my face. What did the pirate say after they plundered the other boat? What? Bye matey! It's so fun hanging out with you guys. Bye gang! Rob Armjarf and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.